- [Voiceover] As we've already
seen in the last few videos,
with the war officially
starting in September of 1939,
the Axis powers get momentum
through the end of 1939,
all the way into 1940.
That was the last video that
we covered and that takes us
to 1941 and what we're
gonna see in 1941 which is
the focus of this video is
that the Axis powers only seem
to gain more momentum.
Because of all of that momentum they
perhaps gets a little bit
overconfident and stretch
themselves or begin to
stretch themselves too thin.
So let's think about what happens in 1941.
So, if we talk about early
1941 or the Spring of 1941,
in March, Bulgaria decides
to join the Axis powers.
You can imagine there's a lot
of pressuring applied to them
and they kind of see
where the momentum is.
Let's be on that side.
Bulgaria joins the Axis and then in
North Africa you might remember
that in 1940, the Allies,
in particular, the British,
were able to defeat the Italians
and push them back into Libya
but now in March of 1941, the
Italians get reinforcements,
Italian reinforcements and also
German reinforcements
under the command of Rommel
the Desert Fox, famous desert
commander and they are able to
push the British back to the
Egyptian border and they also
take siege of the town of Tobruk.
Now, you might have
noticed something that I just drew.
The supply lines in the
North Africa campaign are very,
very, very long and that's
part of the reason why there's one side.
One side has supply lines and as they
start to make progress and as the Allies
make progress and push into
Libya, their supply lines got
really long and so the other
side has an easier timely supply.
Then as the Axis pushes
the Allies back into Egypt,
then their supply lines get
really long and the other
side...it makes it easier for
them to resupply and so North
Africa is kind of defined by
this constant back and forth.
But, by early 1941, it looks
like the Axis is on the
offensive, able to push the
British back into Egypt lay
siege to the town of Tobruk.
So, let me write this
down as North Africa.
So, I'll just say North
Africa over here or
I'll could say Rommel in North Africa
pushing the British back.
And then we can start
talking about what happens in
the Balkans and this is still
in Spring as we go into April
of 1941 and just as a little
bit of background here, and
frankly I should have covered
it a couple of videos ago.
As far back as 1939, actually
before World War II officially
started, in Spring of 1939,
Italy actually occupies Albania
so this actually should
have already been red.
This is in 1939 that this happens and
then at the end of 1940, Italy
uses Albania as a base of
operation to try to invade Greece
but they are pushed back.
Actually one of the reasons why
the British we able to be
pushed back in North Africa is
after they were successful
against the Italians, most of the
bulk of the British forces we
sent to Greece to help defend
Greece at the end of 1940.
So, in 1939, Albania gets taken
over by Italy and at the end
of 1940...October 1940, Greece
is invaded by Italy but they
are then pushed back but to
help the Greeks, the Allies
send many of the forces that
were in North Africa after they
were successful against the
Italians in Libya.
Now, as we go into April of 1941... that
was all background, remember
Albania before the war started
in April 1939, October 1940
was Italy's kind of first push
into Greece and it was unsuccessful.
Then the Greeks get
support from the Allies
in North Africa and now as we go
into 1941, the Germans start
supporting and really take
charge in Balkans and in Greece
and so with the help of the
Germans the Axis is able to
take over Yugoslavia and Greece
and start aerial bombardment of Crete.
So, once again, we're not
even halfway through the year
in 1941 and we see a huge
swath of Europe is under the
control of the Axis powers.
And now we go into the summer of 1941.
This is actually a pivotal
move, what's about to happen.
Now you can imagine that the Axis powers,
in particular, Hitler, are feeling
pretty confident.
We are only about that far into the war.
So we're not even two years
into the war yet and it looks
like the Axis is going to win.
Now you might remember that
they have a pact with the Soviet Union.
Hey, we're gonna split
a lot of Eastern Europe
into our spheres of influence
so to speak, but now Hitler's
like, well, I think I'm ready
to attack and when you attack
the Soviet Union really matters.
You do not want to attack
the Soviet Union in the
winter...or Russia in the winter.
Russia's obviously at the
heart of the Soviet Union.
That something that Napoleon learned.
Many military commanders have learnt.
You do not want to be fighting in Russia
over the winter, so summer of
1941, Hitler figures, hey,
this is the Axis chance.
And so, in June, he decides
to attack the Soviet Union.
So, this is a very, very, very
bold move because now they're
fighting the British.
Remember, the British are kind of not
a joke to be battling out
here in Western Europe and now
they're going to be taking on
the Soviet Union in the east,
a major, major world power.
But at first, like always, it
seems like it's going
well for the Germans.
By September, they're able to
push up all the way to Leningrad.
So, this is September of 1941
and lay lay siege and begin
laying siege to that town.
This is kind of a long bloody
siege that happens there.
So, we're right now, right about there.
And most historians would tell
you that this was one of the
mistakes of Adolph Hitler
because now he is stretched very,
very, very thin.
He has to fight two world powers, Soviet
Union and Great Britain and the
United States hasn't entered
into the war yet and that's
what we're about to get into
because if we go into Asia it
was still in 1941 what happens in July.
So, little bit after
Hitler decides to start
invading the Soviet Union going
back on the pact, the non-
aggression pact.
In July, you could imagine the US, they
were never pleased with what's
been happening, what the
Empire of Japan has been doing
in the Pacific, what they've
been doing in China, in
Manchuria or even in terms of the
war in China, the second
Sino Japanese War.
They weren't happy of the Japanese
taking over French Indochina.
There's a big world power
here, the Empire of Japan.
There's a big world power here,
the United States, that has
a lot of possessions in the
Pacific and so, the United
States in July of 1941...So
remember, this is still all
1941, this is the same
year...decides to freeze the assets
of Japan and probably the most
important part of that was an
oil embargo of Japan.
This is a big, big deal.
Japan is fighting a major
conflict with the Chinese.
It's kind of flexing it's imperial muscles
but it does not have many
natural resources in and of
itself and in fact, that's one
of the reasons why it's trying
to colonize other places to
get more control of natural resources.
And now if it's fighting a war it doesn't
have it's own oil resources and
now there's an oil embargo of
Japan and the United States at
the time was major oil producer
and even today, it's major
oil producer.
This was a big deal to
the Japanese because
some estimates say they only
had about two years of reserves
and they were fighting a war
where they might have to touch
their reserves even more.
So, you could imagine the
Japanese, they want to have
their imperial ambitions.
They probably want, especially now
with this oil embargo, they
probably want to take over
more natural resources and they
probably want to knock out the
US or at least keep the US on
its heels so the US can't
stop Japan from doing what it
wants to do.
So, all it wants in
December 1941, that's over
the course of December 7th
and 8th, and it gets a little
confusing because a lot
of this happens across the
International Date Line.
But over the course of December 7th
and 8th, Japan goes on the
offensive in a major way in the
Pacific.
Over the course of several
hours, at most, a day,
Japan is able to attack
Malaya, which is a British
possession.
It's able to attack Pearl
Harbor, where the US
Pacific fleet is in hope to
knock out the US Pacific fleet
so the US will have trouble
stopping Japan from doing
whatever Japan wants to do.
In the US, we focus a lot on
Pearl Harbor but this was just
one of the attacks in this
whole kind of several hours
of attacks where Japan went on
the offensive.
So, we have Malaya, we
have Pearl Harbor, we
have Singapore, we have Guam,
we have (which was the US
military base), Wake Island.
You have the Philippines, which
was a US possession ever since
the Spanish American war.
You have Hong Kong, which is
a British possession and then
shortly after that as you get
further into December, so this
is kind of when you have Japan offensive.
Then as you go on into later Decemeber,
the kind of real prize for Japan was
what we would now call Indonesia
but the Dutch East Indies.
On this map it says
Netherlands East Indies.
You have to remember the
Netherlands had been overrun.
They're the low countries they were
already overrun by German forces so the
Japanese say hey, look there
are a lot of resources here,
natural resources, especially oil.
Let's go for this and so
by the end of 1941, they're
also going for the Dutch East
Indies and for Burma so you
could imagine it's a very
aggressive, very, very bold
move on Japan but they kind of
had imperial ambitions.
They were afraid of they access to
natural resources so they went
for it but obviously one of
the major consequence of this
is the United States was not
happy about this and they
were already sympathetic to the Allies.
They didn't like what was
going on in Europe either.
going on in China and so that
causes the United States to
enter into World War II on the
side of the Allies and then
the Axis powers to declare war
on the United States,
which was a big deal.